no wonder jesus said take heed
lest the light that is in you be
darkness wow because he he recognizes
some people who think they're in the
light they think they're a light worker
are really walking in darkness
new agers witches pagans even practicers
of law of attraction all call themselves
light workers but what does the term
lightworkers really mean find out on
this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
what's up everybody thank you for
joining us at led live we got a really
exciting show for you today and first
off we just want to say thank you so
much for your support if you guys
support this ministry we cannot do this
without you guys you can support in so
many different ways you can become a
patreon donor which is monthly
supporters or you can even just buy
t-shirts from lightwear.shop and wear
your witness so that you can have a good
icebreaker conversation to start about
spiritual topics and things like that
but we're going to get into the show we
got our guest mike shreve here with us
again man it's always a pleasure having
you on the show it seems like every time
eric wilson comes we get you guys
together and we just get all kinds of
information from you so i love doing
shows with you and today we're going to
talk about light workers well just uh
for the sake of your audience
knowing my background oh yeah the reason
i'm connected with this kind of
information and know how to unravel the
deception is i used to be in it
51 years ago back in 1970 wow it's been
a long time i was a teacher of kundalini
yoga at four universities in the tampa
florida area and i was running a yoga
ashram and had about 300 students who
were coming to my meetings who
considered me
their guru
and incidentally the word guru
in its original form is made of two
words gu and rude that makes sense right
but it means out of darkness
into the light whoa
yeah and so and it's actually translated
teacher
uh it's like rabbi so really we could be
gurus but
true guru but uh anyway there was a huge
problem
because i wasn't in the light yet that's
right so how could i lead anybody else
there did you follow a light worker to
get into the lake well i would have if i
had known the term see this term is
uh not that old it was invented in the
80s
by a guy named michael murdad and he's
an extreme new ager and so it wasn't
used back in my day of involvement in
that
world view before i became a follower of
jesus
but had i known that term i would have
considered myself
a quote-unquote light worker wow because
i was trying to illuminate the world
around me with the light of truth that
was in me and that's part of what a
light worker is supposed to be and
supposed to do and that's the thing we
we present these topics not because
we're trying to attack any type of
people i believe that people are that
that are in this have good intentions
they want to see light and love and
truth and all these things go out but
they're just they've they've believed
what we believe is false according to we
believe the bible that's a very good
point they're they're really genuine
most the time i was because i had
extricated myself from my old life i was
a rock musician
and experienced a drug over oh you
didn't know that yeah i played keyboard
you know right then
but i had a drug overdose experience
where uh i felt like i was transitioning
uh i was i was leaving my body or
whatever was going to happen and i was
dying
and i came back from the experience
it shook me up i thought i can't live
for the vain life i'm living for so i
met this indian guru and started
studying under him oh man so god
preserved your life
and then you went to a yeah another one
direction but like i but you were
seeking from that point forward i never
did drugs never drank alcohol never
watched television never went to movies
didn't involve myself in entertainment
was living a celibate life because i
believed you had to refrain from that
kind of like gnosticism had a belief
like that right
and so i wanted to change
i wanted to be changed so that i could
bring a change
to the world and so i was striving for
higher values i was wrong yeah i was
wrong because i had misinterpreted the
words of jesus and misinterpreted
the bible
that's huge because i often talk about
that i have some of these big thick new
age books for research and it's like the
whole thing is just scripture you know
like
it's christ within you he lives inside
of us and they just skewed scripture to
make it look like if you're not versed
in the truth and you flip open this book
with full of scripture and it's telling
you hey you can manifest and you can
become like christ the christ
consciousness it's very deceptive yeah i
used to use the bible often in teaching
wow yoga classes wow isn't that wild
that's how satan did it right he used
scripture right right once jesus set
that pattern in motion he came back at
him with scripture yeah he said if you
jump off this the angels will catch you
and all this stuff wow so
the enemy likes to validate
deception with little tidbits of truth
yeah or attempt to validate it yeah
because an outright lie is not going to
be accepted it's going to be noticeable
so he
deception is
mostly truth with a little bit of error
right and that's what we try to do on
this show is try to expose that little
bit of error well uh right at the
beginning i was going to quote second
corinthians 11 14 where uh new age
witches
uh call themselves lightworkers right
and uh and
really what sparked this whole
idea in me is my wife did a little image
statement that we put out every day of
the week to put on our facebook pages
and i gave her a statement a few weeks
ago that new age witches often call
themselves lightworkers and no wonder
because even satan disguises himself as
an angel of light
which is second corinthians 11 14.
and so
his tactic is deception and his tactic
is providing a counterfeit for the real
and when you first said light workers i
was thinking
lucifer was called the light bearer
so you can see how how powerful his
delusions his deceptions are because
he's an angel of light and he
um
yeah he's coming to give you truth and
all these things that you're saying you
know coming out of darkness into the
light all these like so close to
biblical terminology but
just a little bit off course
well if you go to some
uh witchcraft websites you'll invariably
find an article
about being a light worker
and because
uh
of that that kind of triggered something
in me i thought why would they consider
themselves lightworkers because they
think they're good witches yeah why
aren't they they think there's a
differentiation and the the guru i
studied under yogi bhajan the founder of
the kundalini yoga cult
he used to say
that
there's three types of witchcraft have
you ever heard that i've heard he said
white magic black magic but he put
another one in there he said there's
black witchcraft which is spiritual
power used for evil purposes
and there's red witchcraft which is
spiritual power used for selfish
purposes
and then there's white witchcraft which
is spiritual power used for noble or
good or righteous
and of course he said yoga
was white witchcraft
but the bible makes no such distinction
it just has a blanket
in fact i've got a scripture here
deuteronomy 18
verses 9 through 13.
god said when you come into the land
which the lord your god has given you
you shall not learn to follow the
abominations of those nations there
shall not be found among you anyone who
makes a son or daughter pass through the
fire or one who practices witchcraft or
a soothsayer or one who interprets omens
or a sorcerer or one who conjures spells
or a medium or spiritus or one who calls
up the dead for all those who do these
things are an abomination to the lord
because of these abominations the lord
your god drives them out from before you
so the practices are abominations and
those who indulge in those practices are
abomination which is a very strong
biblical word
but um it's almost as ironic as saying
like holy pornography or something like
i don't watch the bad pornography yeah i
just watched i only drink christian beer
christian beer yeah
right
i'll only get drunk on christian whiskey
don't misinterpret that folks please
don't listen to her we're showing the
ironicness here but
see uh
there's no such thing as a good witch
because i'd like to stick another word
in those definitions it's not just
spiritual power
yogi bhajan said it all drew from the
same source
because it's all drawing from brahman
which is ultimate reality and hinduism
and impersonal cosmic force
and so uh yeah same thing like in star
wars uh luke skywalker drew his power
from the force right darth vader drew
his power from the forest and they
channeled it into either evil or good
but it's the same source impersonal
and taoism uh promotes that idea
hinduism
for the most part promotes that idea a
little over half of hindus believe that
ultimate reality is brahman and uh that
we are all manifestations of problems is
that so similar to reaching christ
consciousness when you reach brahman
yeah uh that that's the term they use
nirvana
well no nirvana is something different
uh the word nirvana means blowing out
like the blowing out of a candle
and and
uh
there was a big difference in the way
buddha taught as compared to hindus
hindus believe that human beings have a
soul that passes from one incarnation to
the next and buddha taught that we do
not have a soul
but there's five what's called skandas
s-k-a-n-d-h-a skandas that uh come
together to produce a human being and
then disassemble it death
and and the only thing that's left is a
little essence uh or
it's called an unconscious disposition
whatever that is and that passes
supposedly to the next
uh life or whatever but uh nirvana is
the realization that everything is empty
of of
of uh
eternal uh existence everything is empty
of value empty that eventually it's all
going to crumble it's all going to turn
like nihilism so why live
for material things that are only
temporary
and so that's part of the supposed piece
you get in buddhism is really you just
resolve yourself over to the inevitable
but i don't know
why i'm going to cease to exist
eventually yeah so i used to believe
that
when i was atheist agnostic and my
mindset was why not live for all the
material things because i don't have any
reason to have a spiritual life
yeah it's i i think buddhism is the most
pessimistic religion in the world
because it's all based on the idea that
you you have no soul and you have no
permanent existence nothing has a
permanent existence and everything is
empty
uh
and
is it the same it's same religion that
believes in brahman everything is no
hinduism that's hinduism hinduism
believes in brahman which is an ultimate
uh reality of a cosmic energy a cosmic
and we are all brahmana
yeah we're all made up of the state now
not all hindus believe that a little
over 50 percent uh it's called advaita
hinduism a d a-d-v-a-i-t-a
and veda believes that all things are of
one essential substance that we are god
that we are manifestations of brahman
but then quite a few hindus believe in a
personal god
they believe either in vishnu or they
believe in sheba or they believe in
uh
they believe in krishna being ultimate
reality and that they can have a
personal relationship with the god who
is the ultimate expression of divinity
but uh
anyway we're talking about light workers
on
tangents so
the big issue is that there's
uh no such thing as good witches or good
witchcraft yeah and yet
uh people try and label themselves a
light worker because uh well this is a
definition that i found on a website
called
vitalethos.com which is a very new age
website that a light worker is someone
who dedicates their life to channeling
universal energy and wisdom for the
highest good of all beings wow that
sounds pretty nice
do you believe in energies or vibrations
like do you think that's an actual thing
in our world that god designed or is
that just another way of saying like
evil spirits
well
as far as channeling universal energy
that's another way of saying that
there's a divine essence in every human
being and we can all express that
essence which i don't believe now uh i
when i was a yoga teacher i believed
that god was inside of everybody
but then jesus went to the cross and
vain if god's already inside of all of
us
then there's no need for him to down
across to redeem us from our sins so
that he can come and dwell within us and
so but they like like you said they use
scripture to try and prove that uh like
for instance when jesus said i think it
was in luke chapter 17 where he said the
kingdom of god is
within and he made it sound like that's
a blanket statement for everyone but
when you really take it in context he
was talking to his detractors he was
talking to people that were refuting his
claim to being the messiah and uh and i
believe it was his way
of
of speaking hypothetically just like if
you tell someone who is um
very hung up on material things you'll
say peace is not in the car you own or
the house you live in or the status
symbols you've got or the
position you hold in this corporation
peace is within you but this person's
afraid and nervous and anxious they
don't have peace yet but you're speaking
hypothetically you're saying if you
discover peace you won't find it
externally you'll find it internally
and and in the same way when he said the
kingdom of heaven is within you or the
kingdom of god is within you he wasn't
actually declaring that these people who
were calling him a blasphemer had the
kingdom of god in them
he was saying if you ever discovered it
will be an internal experience yeah it's
your character it's the thing that that
makes uh you you god wants to preserve
our the character which is his character
holiness and so you can be
that type of character now man on earth
yeah and so that's that's it's a
phenomenal thing and so christ was well
the kingdom of god is pervaded with the
character of god
it's saturated with the character of god
so that when we're born into the kingdom
like you say we we come into the
character of god and that's when we
become more like him gradually from more
from glory to glory yeah from the glory
kind of speaking what you're saying
about vibrations and stuff like that i
think i think in the new age and in the
occult and that kind of stuff i think
there's like we said deception a lot of
truth a little bit error i think satan
knows a lot of what god has created and
things like that and he just skews this
type of stuff because i mean you can
look at uh sound waves and they make
these beautiful
uh see what's the word symmetrical
patterns and stuff geometric patterns
and there's no denying that that's a
reality that's true but then satan comes
along and says no we got all these good
vibes and all this stuff you know like
so i really do think that there's kind
of a little bit of truth and a lot just
like
we know that god created natural things
remedies and cures for diseases but then
you go
to the new age or witchcraft and they're
you know binding up sage and all these
things
it's like there's a subtle
deception there yeah so i was just
wondering like it's safe
if you were a stranger and then i just
walked away from like okay i got really
bad vibes from him because that's really
big in our in our world today it's like
vibrations frequencies and i mean like
when you're out in nature
um let's say you're away from like the
cities and you're out in nature and it's
like does do the trees um
like send off something that makes your
brain feel really calm or like just
things like that so wondering if these
things are
are actual
like do they actually exist like do
energies actually exist it's just that
satan takes it and uses it i'm not sure
i would call it
energies always okay of course the the
connotation yeah of a new age
interpretation is there if you call it
energies
if you come around a person
that's got demonic activity in his life
of course even if you're an unsaved
person that doesn't have discernment
you're going to feel
uncomfortable that's what i was thinking
uh so
but i you have to be careful about
terminology yeah because like when i
pray
i always meditate
too when i pray which is
from a biblical stance we did a program
on this it means to meditate on the word
calmly in the presence of god
prayerfully and expecting the holy
spirit to help you interpret what you
read not emptying your mind not emptying
your mind but filling your mind but uh i
also
want to transcend when i pray i meditate
and i want to transcend
to a higher place spiritually where i'm
more sensitive to the presence of god
but i'm not going to call it
transcendental meditation right
but even though i want to transcend and
i intend to meditate yeah
what i always like to say is satan's a
master he's a master at redefining words
right so he'll take like a meditation
and then he'll say oh yeah it's
meditation but it's not the same
meditation that we're thinking of that's
biblical where you're focused on what's
god's saying and how he's saying it and
that
thinking about his you know the love of
god whereas meditation is like empty
yourself and get rid of all the stuff
and so you can have an emptiness of
yours of yourselves
mystical experiences yeah yeah well like
even buddhists uh
don't believe in
god or
the basis of buddhism is atheism so when
they meditate they're not going to be
meditating on god or on the things of
god or on the word of god because they
don't believe in god but on the same
website ethos.com
after this maybe i should re
read this again a light worker is
someone who dedicates their life to
channeling universal energy and wisdom
for the highest good of all beings and a
little further on the description
continues during their time in this
realm
lightworkers strive to transcend their
ego
and commit fully to serving others with
love and compassion man it sounds so
good it doesn't have sex
where's jesus he's nowhere exactly
where's the experience of being born
again nowhere how do you know what love
is and so this is striving for a very
um
notable and wonderful goal humanistic
within your own human ability yeah and
and and some of the people like you said
that strive for this goal really have a
genuine attitude of heart
but you can't get there
unless you go through jesus he meant
what he said in john 14 6 when he said i
am the way the truth and the life and no
one can come to god but by me
i thought this would help us
by the way i want to mention again the
guy that termed
this uh or
originated this term the guy that was
the first one
to talk about light workers is a guy
named michael murdad
and he's got a website michael murdad
m-i-r-d-a-d
uh
dot-com
and and he advertises on his website
what he does is michael's work focuses
on soul level healing spiritual mastery
creating healthy relationships and here
you go awakening christ's consciousness
our divine selves so they're you know a
full blast new age
because they believe that christ is a
principle not a person yeah
and that it's a principle
of a divine essence in every human being
that can be awakened and you're going to
be blown away by the information i bring
in just a little bit
about this whole concept of christ
consciousness i i just wanted to add to
that thing about love um because it says
you know that they wanted to serve
others and love and compassion like
that's you know jesus talked about that
serving others and loving others but in
first john 4 7
or i'll start with six first john 4 6 it
says
we are of god he that knoweth god
heareth us he that is not of god heareth
not us hereby know we that
uh we the spirit of truth and spirit of
error
beloved let us love one another for love
is of god and everyone that loveth is
born of god and knoweth god he that
loveth not knoweth not god for god is
love
and this
was manifested the love of god towards
us because that god sent his only
begotten son into the world that we
might live through him we cannot really
fully love
because god is love and without god we
cannot be capable of love so if
somebody's denying
the god of the bible
and jesus christ then they're they
really can't even cert complete their
mission that they're on you know right
it's like uh having the framework of a
house like all the two by fours
in place
but there's no sheet rock yeah and
there's no roof
and so they have the framework of a life
that's worth living
but they haven't filled it in with them
because we all have this
they call it the god-shaped vacuum in us
and we're all searching for it yeah
we're all like
i'm looking for something what is it and
they're going down the road at the new
age and the occult and sometimes it's
sex drugs and alcohol and all these
things because this brings me some kind
of comfort or happiness but it's always
this short lasting counterfeit and they
have
the exact
framework they want the things of the
bible but they've probably been hurt by
somebody in the church they've probably
seen
hypocritical christians and so they're
rejecting the truth
but they want the truth you know that's
why it's so important for us to truly
live a christian life to walk jesus
christ and don't you think too that
part of it is
the only part of the human spirit that
is still functional
um
i believe in three parts to a human
being spirit soul and body
uh we've never discussed this i don't
know if that's your
mindset too
but i believe each one of those has
three functions primary parts
uh the body is made up of flesh bones
and blood the soul is made up of mind
will and emotions
and the spirit has three functions
revelation from god communion with god
and conscience well prior to being saved
revelation from god is non-existent
the only thing left is the conscience in
a fallen state it's like a barely
burning ember where there used to be a
raging fire
and i believe the conscience in us
drives us toward goals like this yeah i
got to be a loving person right i need
to be compassionate i need to spread
light in a dark world so
it may start the conscience is not the
essence of god within people
that's they mistake it as the quote
unquote higher self right and and that
the higher self is one with brahman and
and so they attribute it to the christ
consciousness that needs to be awakened
in us i believe the conscience is just a
gift from god to fallen human beings to
keep us from fully going down the tube
right and it's even amazing that they
call it christ conscious it's not like
universal conscience like
this just shows how subtle the deception
is how satan wants to counterfeit but
even in the new age they believe in
christ you know just not the christ
was one of the first gurus to come over
to this country
and he was a master
i'm not praising him he was a master
at using christian terminology
to define
far eastern doctrine that's something
more than any other group that i've ever
studied about or read
because he knows that
america is kind of like a christian
nation so if he's going to get more
converts he's got a yeah yeah the
package right and he succeeded
but the guy that won me to the lord was
one of his students and really and then
he became a christian i need to hear
your testimony again we have his
testimony on our channel i need to check
it out yeah so i have a question about
about that i'm sorry finish your thought
before no no no because in my next
thought it's going to take a while
because okay so so christian
christ consciousness
you know jiminy cricket from disney all
used to say you know what i'm going to
say
always let your conscience be your guide
right and so is consciousness kind of
this new age idea i mean that's kind of
what you were talking about whereas i
would say always let the holy spirit be
your god right and so is there is that
what you're saying but there's a
difference is different than
consciousness yeah yeah but they're kind
of related because if you live according
to the dictates of your conscience
you will live a conscious life in new
age terminology and a conscious life is
living on that higher level of
compassion and love and peace and not
being
an egotistical person not being
uh an angry person a selfish person a
proud person etc to live a conscious
life is to live
according to the dictates of your higher
self and and again i think they mistake
the conscience
as
a higher aspect of their self that is
actually already
one with that's the divine self yeah
kind of revealing itself or whatever
you're awakening to that divine self and
that's why they think i don't need jesus
because i've already got this desire
this connection in me
but um thank god he reveals himself and
he makes a difference i thought this
would help us find out about what light
workers really are
on the same website vitalethos.com
they list 25 surprising signs that
you're a light worker now i didn't think
we'd have time to go through all of them
so i embolded the ones that
seem to be more important and i'll just
read through maybe six or seven and then
we can discuss it if you like number one
you often feel the presence of invisible
forces oh so you've got spiritual
sensitivity
number two you feel like an outsider and
you don't fit in anywhere
isn't it
and number three you've survived the
dark knight of the soul
well i don't even know that
yeah
lost there you've gone through something
well when i had my drug overdose
experience at the age of uh 18. i think
that's where you're at a crossroads in
life after you come out of something
like that so it's easy like i need to
make sure i need to do something with my
life yeah number four is your unusually
lucky which is a sign the universe is
affirming your path wow and of course i
did a a podcast not long ago uh titled
does the universe really love you
and my point was that it's an inanimate
universe stars and planets are inanimate
they don't have consciousness right and
so the universe cannot have your back
the universe cannot love you and the
universe cannot grant your desires well
not only that but love it has been
manifested as a weak sentimentalism
nowadays so it has that feeling and
people people think the love is oh they
have that loving feeling towards you but
love is not a feeling it's a a duty that
brings a feeling right what what's
what's the best form or example of love
that we know of christ's daughter and
yourselves right when he was in the
garden of gethsemane he didn't feel like
he was wanting to finish this but he
said not your will
but not not my will but your yours be
done so the best example of love love is
that duty that we have to do the will of
god no jesus even said that uh that love
is laying down your life for your
friends you know something the universe
can't do yeah
yeah absolutely
uh number five is you easily
quote unquote manifest your desires
that's the law of attraction yeah law of
attraction that thoughts become things
and that well the basis for the law of
attraction is the belief that we are god
exactly which is the polar opposite of
the truth but if you believe you are god
and your thoughts have created power
then your thoughts become things and
that's a sign you're becoming a light
worker because you're moving into that
arena where your thoughts are powerful
number six
you believe in and and again i don't
think we should throw the baby out with
the bathwater exactly because thoughts
do make a difference yeah and that's
that's what i was going to say we did a
whole show on law of attraction the
church and we showed all these pastors
using this terminology and stuff like
you can manifest and all this stuff and
it's like man it's so close to the truth
like there's a lot of truth in there but
the way they're doing it
is it takes you away from the
sovereignty of god we showed a lot of
them where they're looking i look at
this picture of money every day and i
say
you come to me money come to me and it's
like okay is that really what god wants
for your life it's hard for a rich man
to enter the kingdom of god right so you
know what and we don't have time to go
this direction
but i i just did an article on my
website on the truelight.net
uh on what does the 100 volt promise
really mean
that'd be interesting and it's
completely different uh these preachers
will say if you'll give a hundred
dollars it'll come back to you
that's not what jesus said absolutely
not but jesus we're gonna put a link to
that in the description
he actually was telling his disciples to
give up everything right not to bargain
with god to get
and he never mentioned money he said
to those that had sacrificed to follow
him he said you'll risk you've
sacrificed
your lives to follow him to take up your
cross he said you'll receive a hundred
full brothers and sisters mothers and
fathers he was talking about the
increase of genuine covenant
relationships that you'll get in your
life
by becoming a follower of christ but
anyway that's another story
and then um
number eight and i'm jumping some
because i don't want to go through all
25. you feel empathy for other beings
so you you you're sensitive to the pain
of others
and that helps you know you're really a
light worker so far i'm a light worker
i think
you could put it in different
terminology that's acceptable that
you're becoming a mature human being
right when it's not all about you
and you're closer to being able to
produce light in a dark world
but um so
like you said mixture of truth and error
number nine you can sense past and
future events because light workers
often have psychic abilities
and uh
i won't elaborate on that number 11
let's jump to number 11. you can easily
enter a trance-like state
but then that's uh self-created visions
and i believe if you get a vision or a
men
if you give some kind of manifestation
like a danger of a dream or a vision
from god
that god is the initiator
what i'm saying is you can't
force yourself to have a dream that's
from god or a vision that's from god
which is
uh what they're talking about that
you're the one like i'm about to get a
vision from god right now yeah all right
how do you know when a dream is from god
versus oh wow that's another present
because i've noticed that sometimes like
i'll have dreams but i realize that it's
just a collection of either what's going
on in my life or something that someone
had said and then i literally dream
about it and you can easily i mean like
think wow
i've been serving god 50 years plus yeah
and there's a handful of times that i
know without a shadow of a doubt
that it was god speaking to me in a
dream where i heard his voice and when
you hear his voice it's unmistakable and
the ultimate thing is test it with the
word of god if it if it
contradicts god then you know it's not
of god but now this next point
about you know the 25 surprising signs
you are a light worker the next point on
this new age website says number 12 you
attract friends and lovers who have a
dark side what's good about that i guess
because there's somebody's a witness to
because if you're a quote unquote light
worker oh you're drunk you're always
willing to repair damaged lives so you
kind of attract damaged people a lot of
women like that
let's jump to number 16. you are good at
neutralizing conflicts
because light workers are skilled at
bringing positive vibes into negative
situations
uh number 19 you often notice
synchronicities and unusual patterns
that's me bro every day all day i was
gonna bring it up i didn't know it was
in here but dude i've seen it since high
school man like
synchronicities all the time i don't
know what else to call it i just know
that it's
crazy patterns all the time in my life
and they're just weird and it's crazy
because you were talking about how
like when i was out there and i said
yeah i'm living the good life and then
he had just like read something
that said the same thing the good life
yeah and he was like what why would you
say that synchronicity yeah like i'm
telling you i i bring it up to people i
kind of share with others and then they
start noticing it too and it's like some
people just say well it's just like when
you buy that nissan car now you just see
a bunch of nissans because you notice it
but it's not like that it's like really
weird stuff like the radio all the
sudden is playing johnny cash and it's
like i haven't heard this in years and
then
you turn on the tv and johnny cash is on
there it's just like
what are the chances of that well
sometimes that's random yeah
sometimes is demonic if it's going to
take you the wrong direction
and sometimes it's god right and and i
think god is at work in the world he's
at work among unsaved people and there
are times when i know that's what i'm
saying when it's random stuff like
johnny cash or whatever i don't know
what to think but when it's like
i'm going through a situation and that
very day somebody calls me and they say
they share their testimony and it's
exactly what i'm going through it's like
confirmation affirmation and then the
next day it happens again i'm like wow
if these people would have came to me
even a month ago i couldn't have
identified the way i can now and like
thank you lord for giving this
encouragement that i needed today you
know and it's important to be sensitive
to those things yeah synchronicity like
they're going through they're telling me
something that happened that i'm going
through right now
i feel like synchronicity would be
you see a sign that says something or
someone said something to you and then
you saw a sign like three days later
that said something similar right it is
like that but i'm saying when i know
it's of god it's the types of
affirmation confirmation that's
something i don't really know what to do
with the synchronicity type stuff but i
know when it's of god in isaiah 45 it
says that god is barely a god who hides
himself
and i think one of the ways god hides
himself is in these synchronicities that
happened in our life instead of
blatantly just speaking like an audible
voice from mount sinai
he makes us pick up on that like when my
wife and i got a diagnosis in her fifth
month of pregnancy that her daughter had
spina bifida and cretinism that she
would be unable to walk and probably
unable to talk and then the doctor
suggested abortion we jumped up to leave
because we didn't want to be around him
and as we left
god spoke to my wife audibly she heard
the audible voice of god he said your
daughter will dance
on the streets of jerusalem the doctor
just told her she'd never walk wow and
we got to the car and my wife hasn't
told me what she just heard yet and
she's not the kind of person to say i
heard the voice of god right
if she says that it happened
but we got to the car and she turned the
radio on you reminded me of this and it
came on that country christian song i
hope you dance oh by leanne yeah
woman
yeah she started crying she said mike
it's a confirmation god just told me our
daughter would dance
and so it's a long story but when she
was born she was born perfect praise the
lord
i've had it i've had another experience
like that too where i was just praying
to god and saying lord just
um be my guiding light in this dark
world and i just was like really
intimately praying with god and i was a
valet and had all these cars stacked up
and it was just me alone and i had to
rearrange them i get in the car i turn
on the radio i turn up i just crank the
car and the radio comes on
and it's something like old bg's song or
something but they literally say like
you're my light in this shining or
you're oh is that how deep is your love
probably yeah and i was just like you
know it's weird to think that god would
use some secular song or something but i
i just wept dude i was like whoa yeah i
was just praying that and these words
come on
you know if god can speak through an ass
you know then he can speak through a bg
song i guess but not not endorsing to
listen to the bgs but yeah yeah yeah
well i mean isn't it also dangerous
though i mean because we could i mean i
absolutely believe that he can speak
through synchronicities before we get i
mean actually let me read the
definitions i had to look it up i'm glad
you're bringing this
before i get into that i'm like
multi-threading here
okay so synchronicity is the
simultaneous occurrence sometimes
concurrence of events which appear
significantly related but have no
discernible cause or connection because
i i didn't know anything about this at
the time
so i just started sharing what was
happening in my life and people like oh
that's synchronicities and yeah i knew
it was like having a new age terminal
and so like i said a few minutes ago
they can come from three sources they
can just be random
and
just something that happens
uh strangely with no real cause but they
can be demonic
and if people are
are always looking for synchronicity
they're going to see them more often and
the enemy will take advantage of that
but then it can also be god but
supposedly if you have sensitivity in
that area that's a sign that you're
probably i keep pushing this documentary
called beware of angels but when you
said when you're looking for it satan
can jump on that there was this
documentary is based on a story of
uh two sisters that were having these
bible studies and they just
really had a desire to want to know more
about the bible we want to we want to
know more deeper truth like give us
revelation in the in the bible angels
came and spoke to people we want an
angel to appear and an angel appeared
and started
built a relationship with them over five
years they had piles of they had
interactions with like a hundred and six
right there this is all documented in
legal stuff this is just really
interesting stuff yeah like multiple
people were at this bible study this
angel was appearing and called himself
naked truth
and um
but anyway over would tell them things
scriptural like twist scripture to look
like different things
and then over a period of five years
finally got to a point where he said
look certain people are fully manifested
demons like they've been infiltrated by
demons and they're literally like a
demon manifest
and god is calling you to kill this
person this person this person this
husband wife and their son because
they're fully manifest demons they're
like we're not going to kill anybody and
he said
you if you refuse to do what god has
called you to do
you'll be an unredeemable person you'll
become that fully manifested demon so
imagine being faced with that you've
prayed that god would give you an angel
to give you deeper truth in the bible
you know you're not trying to get into
the new age or anything this angel
appears
builds your trust and then tells you to
do something like this
man that's like deception on a whole
another level man it's like that's deep
but like you said when you're
they asked jesus for a sign and he said
an adulteress a wicked and adulterous
nation asked for a sign but no signs
because yeah generation because he has
his word that's all he needs like if we
never saw a single sign in life it would
be just because we have his word and
it's our duty to read that word and and
know what god's will is yeah and satan
man he can do all kinds of signs and
miracles and many people are going to
fall from the faith giving heed to
seducing spirits and doctrines of demons
because of miracles signs and wonders
and how did jesus overcome he quoted
scripture right every single time ah the
three times the satan came to him and
said i will give you this i will do this
you will you know uh throw yourself down
otherwise uh you know
angels will pick you up and and
he said no no scripture doesn't say that
he's written he's written
that's always amazed me that even though
he was the word made flesh
in the midst of a spiritual battle he
reverted to the written word wow
and so that that just all the more puts
it up on the pedestal for me
oh i'm sorry go ahead
um just thinking about the bible story
from not the bible story but the story
about the beware right now yeah beware
of angels
when and knowing that there's dark magic
and white magic and red magic
if you are in
white magic or you start off there do
you eventually is the goal to lead you
to dark magic no
no white witches think that they're
using the spiritual power for good right
like you know like like uh
oh what was that lord of the rings yeah
you've got the one sorcerer that's given
over
to evil and then gandalf yeah supposedly
the good one um
but it's all uh illegitimate power see i
stick the word illegitimate because
witchcraft whether it's black witchcraft
red witchcraft or
white witchcraft it's all illegitimate
spiritual power because it doesn't come
from god it's sourced in a demonic
influence but yeah it doesn't have to
lead you to that dark stuff because
satan i say this all time to satan has a
tackle box full of different bait like
hey don't you want to play ouija boards
you're like no that's dark and evil what
about new age it's all colorful and
lights and love you know so it doesn't
matter about that because i'm thinking
like
when i was in new age and i was going
like i remember the point where i was
like
was the witchcraft part but they were
saying you can use witchcraft for good
let's say i were to go down the
witchcraft path and then i were to see
ouija boards differently and said oh i
want to connect with my dead mother or
whoever and it's like does it lead you
well it does lead you there because i
would i would assume that at some point
i mean maybe i'm wrong like lucifer
would just try to like uh
kind of prep you so that he can fully
reveal himself and you accept it right
well it may not be the person's motive
but it's satanic the motive of satanic
powers to take you down the dark path
eventually to snare you with a false
light
no wonder jesus said take heed
lest the light that is in you be
darkness wow because he he recognizes
some people who think they're in the
light they think they're a light worker
are really walking in darkness and they
just don't know it yet but point number
22 in this list and for those
that uh have forgotten what we're doing
is a list of 25 signs that your light
worker found on a website called vital
ethos and this is this is not correct
stuff yeah
but number 22 is you believe strongly in
reincarnation
and and this is the the catcher
and sensitive people realize you are an
old soul oh i've heard people say that
yeah like he was an old soul that me
you're a light worker because you've
been reincarnated many times you've
learned lots of lessons and you become a
more wise person so you can help foolish
wise find their way through life so
you're an old soul
no
that is not correct
but that's part of this list
and then number 24 is you have a strong
urge to help others make the world a
better place
and number 25 you have experienced
a profound spiritual shift in your life
in your lifetime now i've got a bunch of
websites here i won't go to them but
this is where it's the law of
attraction.com
and they have an article there 14 signs
of being a lightworker so followers of
the law of attraction consider
themselves like workers and yet you'll
never find the plan of salvation
in in the secret or any article about
the law
in fact uh in fact you won't probably
find the name jesus anyway right so they
exclude the whole path to maybe to say
in history there was a good guru named
jesus or something if you go to this
website witches and pagans.com
which is in pagans.com there's an
article there on being lightworkers
so you can be a pagan a pagan somebody
that believes in
the divine essence in nature you kind of
worship god through nature you believe
in the goddess and the god
and things like that but uh witches and
pagans feel like there
but this is the one that blew me away
you know mark downey and uh or mark
burnett and roma downey you know roman
reigns touch financial yeah
i think roma is probably a very sincere
loving person is she the actress the
player the angel yeah she played the
angel and in those
movies or in those shows touched by an
angel sometimes she really
presents
some powerful concepts about character
and dealing with pain in your life and
dealing with tragedy and trauma
that are really applicable across the
board of course it's not sufficient
right if you don't go to jesus you've
only got a
a partial answer not the whole answer
but anyway
they they were the ones that produced
the bible series on tv a number of years
ago did you ever see the bible says yeah
then they did a d after yeah yeah it was
pretty good
i had a i had a hard time with the
angels using taekwondo or judo
on the people in sodom and gomorrah you
know
i thought that was a little
more than cheesy that was really crazy
but they like to call themselves the
noisiest christians in hollywood because
they produced a film called resurrection
recently it showed around
time
passover time
and
they've been a very strong influence in
hollywood to produce bible-based
programming however
their production company is called
light workers wow
interesting and
they have a website now an online
community
that is
lightworkers.com wow
so i thought whoa just wait a moment and
i started doing
and again i believe roma is a genuine
loving person i don't think she can
talk the way she talks without having a
genuine desire to spread goodness right
which i don't i don't condemn that but
on lightworkers.com
you won't see the crucifixion of jesus
mentioned you won't see the resurrection
of jesus mentioned
you won't see the name of jesus mitch
as far as i know uh what i look through
is all about spreading goodness and
seeing the good in everyone and making
the world a better place which
i have no
fight against but that's not enough yeah
that's not your identity is in christ
you can't talk
without talking about christ yeah this
is a line from lightworkers.com
to celebrate life by looking for the
good in everything and everyone
well wait a second i'm not going to look
for the good in a muslim
yeah uh i may well let me rephrase that
i may try to find inroads into his life
if if he's got some good qualities i may
try and pick those qualities out and
and use that as an inroad to bring the
gospel to him but it's not enough for me
to just find goodness in people
i've got to lead them to jesus well
jesus said there's none good but one
right right
absolutely but this is something that's
uh two more things i want to mention
about roman is she worked with
dela reese
uh adela rhys was one of the angels okay
are you familiar with who i'm talking
about you kind of touched about angel
yeah yeah dela reis i remember that show
was the head angel you know she and and
she monica was under her authority you
know and monica was assisting her in
these various people that
situation where they tried to help
people
but i tried to reach de la reis i've met
delaries
and she's gone on now she's died a
number of years ago but um
she pastored a church in hollywood
called the up church
and
yeah and
and it stands for um
well
i can't remember what it stands for but
it it means
basically having
the right way of looking at life the up
church
and i went there and i was blown away
because
it was like a full blast worship service
in a pentecostal charismatic church to
begin with i mean the people were
vibrant they were emotional they were
worshiping god and then all of a sudden
the guy got up to speak
and jesus was relegated to an inferior
position where he was just a wayshower
wow he was no longer the savior of the
world
he was just a wayshower who showed us
how to awaken our own divinity
and so
imagine how many christians got lured in
there because they're like look at this
fun a vibrant church these people are on
fire and they go in there and they start
oh the pastor said this and then
everything is good and every path is
good and all religions are good and and
and it seems like harmony and love and
peace and i believe that's what that's
where the new world religion is gonna go
peace and safety you know it's gonna
look like
love peace is gonna be so close to the
truth that people are gonna fall for it
but it's gonna be this like universalism
type thing new age basically
absolutely and then i did some more
research
and found out um that roma downey
graduated from a new age university
and
gave some very strong endorsements later
on in life he was hired by universities
but how many no i wasn't hired they gave
me facilities i mean you got the
practice and extracurricular in the same
way they have christian
universities they have new age ones yeah
it's the university of santa monica
and the guy that founded it
also founded a movement called the
movement of spiritual inner awareness
which is uh you can look it up it's just
basically another
new age type of approach
that
that excludes jesus
and and makes it unnecessary so my point
is
that even though they claim to be
christian and are celebrated and i don't
know their hearts i don't know mark and
roma i know that she reveres delaries as
being a real mentor in her life
and if de la reis was totally new
thought in new age in her mindset then
that makes me think that most likely
roma is as well right and yet you'll go
to the nrb national religious
broadcasters meetings and roma will be
one of the speakers sometimes
because
there's not enough discernment there's
not enough awareness in the church of
the distinction between the false light
in the true light that's so true man
that new age has infiltrated the church
in so many different ways it's scary
luke 11 35 take heed that the light that
is in you be not darkness
and then john chapter 1 verse 19 jesus
is the true light that lights everyone
who comes into the world and if he's the
true light that implies there's a false
line too so make sure you have the true
light
and then
i would never use the term light worker
right i would not say i'm a light worker
but jesus said you are the light of the
world all right so we're called to walk
in the light even as he is in the even
as he is the light and we're called to
radiate the light of truth in this world
so
i hope a lot of light workers get saved
and really become the light of the world
as a result of this program amen well
thank you so much for sharing your
wisdom in this you have a lot of
background in this and if you want to
check out his website it is called
thetruelight.net the truelight.com you
can actually download a booklet called
the highest adventure encountering god
it's a small
booklet that is free it's available in
nine languages yes they're in chinese
japanese spanish portuguese several
german some other languages and it talks
about how i came out of eastern
religions yoga and meditation and became
a follower of jesus awesome if you want
to see his testimony in full we're going
to put that in the description box but
this has been really enlightening if you
will
we hope you guys come back next time if
you know anybody that's kind of going
down the road of this
new agey witchcraft stuff that they
believe is the true light share this
program with them we really hope that
this is be eye opening for them and we
could bless them in many ways don't
forget to hit subscribe like this thing
if you just were blessed by this a
simple thumbs up really helps get us
into the algorithm helps get this out to
other people who need to see it and we
love you and we'll see you guys next
week
there has been
very few movies in the history of the
world that have completely changed our
world
and in 1999 a movie titled the matrix
hit the world stage these stories are
often told and seen over and over again
is it simply just to make money
or is there something more nefarious
behind it
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
you